what do you say the Americans were  scared though I guess nearly 200 dead  14,000 you're sick millions as you  witness who are scared right now  way to say to Americans we're watching  you right now you're scared I say that  you're a terrible reporter that's what I  say I think it's a very nasty question  and I think it's a very bad signal that  you're putting out to the American  people the American people are looking  for answers and they're looking for hope  and you're doing sensationalism and the  same with NBC and Comcast I don't know I  don't know what Comcast I call it  Comcast just that for whom you work let  me just say something that's really bad  reporting and you want to get back to  report a good set of sensationalism  let's see if it works  it might and it might not I happen to  feel good about it but who knows I've  been right a lot let's see what happens  John